you know I'm having a hard time deciding
which weapon to eviscerate this movie
with Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles you
could probably guess from my intro piece
what I think of this movie but before
you take a look at how old I am and
immediately dismiss this opinion as
being nostalgia because I'm too in love
with the 80s cartoon just a tiny bit of
context yes the cartoon and the action
figures was my initial introduction I
had a couple I think maybe three VHS
sort of collections of episodes I didn't
see a ton of the cartoon but it piqued
my interest enough that I ended up
special ordering collected volumes of
the original comic books which honestly
for the ages that I was I probably
shouldn't have been reading and those
four volumes I read over and over again
and that is the version of the turtles
that I truly love this version I don't
know why it exists I don't know who it's
for and I don't know what they're trying
to do first off its got the Transformers
problem which is that the title
characters are actually not the main
heroes of the story the main hero is
April O'Neil and this is made worse by
the fact that she's played by Megan Fox
not entirely Megan Fox's fault what is
written is crap she just went bundles
her way from scene to scene and then
says out loud her revelations of the
plot what's going on but just thought we
already figured out and just makes her
seem like a bigger idiot for announcing
it like it's some big revelation and the
biggest single misstep is gonna be
shredder basically it's very clear that
as originally written the character of
Eric sacks is supposed to be shredder
but when fans found that out and called
foul day very hastily crowbarred in this
other character to be the shredder but
that actually kind of makes it worse
because now the shredder is really just
a glorified inch men because Eric sacks
is still the main villain and addressing
him real quickly his motivation is
beyond stupid the reason he's doing his
big evil scheme is to be rich basically
he had started a project which was
supposed to be schemed to get him rich
now that got full he didn't get to do
that now things have changed and he's
able to kick-start that plan again but
he's become rich in the interim already
like rich enough that the guy has a
compound and a personal army how much
richer does he need to be it just it may
no Sammy then that's another thing this
film does not make internal sense
there's a point where splinter is sort
of recounting more of the backstory but
at one point he refers to April's father
who is turned into a scientist who
helped in the creation of the Turtles
just to tie her into the turtles because
at one point splinter says that her
father discovered the plans of the
shredder now he says this before having
identified who the shredder is how he
knows who the shredder is why they
should be scared of the shredder and
none of the other people he's telling
the story to which is all four Turtles
and April go wait wait wait who's the
shredder and that I think really comes
to the heart of what's wrong with this
movie it's a reboot which means they get
to do new things but not only do they
not do anything new but then the film
tries to have it both ways because it's
doing everything new again but it's
giving us stuff that would only have
relevance and poignancy if it was in the
context of us already knowing and
understanding these things take for
example there is a fight between
splinter and shredder and it's played in
the movie like this is some big epic
showdown except you take it within the
context of this film by itself it's not
these characters have never met before
we don't understand why splinter knows
who the shredder is the shredder has no
idea who's splinter is here there's no
history but the film plays it up as if
they do but it's only epic if you take
into context everything that came before
it but this movie doesn't count all that
because it's a new continuity and things
like that just happened over and over
and over again like the fact that
they're even ninjas and this one is a
complete coincidence because splinter
now he's just a rat he's a lab rat he
was never been owned by Hamato Yoshi he
just happened to find a book on ninjutsu
and raised the turtles to be that yet
he's still the same really tuned in sort
of Zen mastery thing that he always has
been except before it made a tiny bit of
sense because he personally had a
history was kind of raised in that
culture now he wasn't he literally just
found a book that somebody threw away
and suddenly he's
my master of ninjutsu what and then
coming back to shredder not only is
there no reason for him to be a separate
character for America sacks there's no
reason for him to even be a ninja he
doesn't have that history of sort of
being the dark sides as far as lights I
didn't you know think it's just sheer
dumb coincidence and the fact that he's
a ninja and factors into absolutely
nothing because the Foot Clan our ninja
the book lands is a paramilitary outfit
but it's just stuck in there because
well he's always been an indolent well
look if you're not gonna back it up
within the context of your reboot then
you need to drop it you either need to
re-establish this stuff or you don't get
to use it and that's the thing this bill
does not have the strength of his own
convictions I think at the beginning
before little nuggets about the film
started coming out and fans started
crying foul they probably had a stronger
sense of identity for the film itself
but as fans started to scream about the
various things that they were hearing
that they didn't like and the film then
adapted and reacted to that it became
this Himanta as well we got to be sure
we give them all the things they like
but all it does is check off things on a
checklist for what are supposed to be in
the turtles but never bothers to justify
their existence in the film or within
the story itself now smell at this time
and I haven't actually talked about the
turtles themselves I'm not going to talk
too much about them physically in the
redesign I don't love it but that's not
what breaks it what breaks it is they
are boiled down to a single trait of
peace and that unto itself wouldn't be a
deal breaker because in a lot of ways
they've always kind of been single
trained characters to a certain extent
but they take that one trait and blow it
up to such ridiculous proportions that I
hated all of them Raphael is my Jew this
is my favorite turtle he's been my
favorite turtle every single incarnation
of this story I hated him in this movie
because Raphael is the hothead but here
they blow that up so that he delivers
every line as us angry shout hmm I
wanted him to just shut up and they do
that with all the turtles Donatello has
always been kind of into technology and
a little bit of heat so now they out Fat
geek quotient to the point that he wears
glasses he
can deliver a simple line without
pressing it with by nine calculations
they even have him do a snort laughs and
then there's Michelangelo and apparently
somebody decided that his party nature
blown up means he really really really
wants to bang April it's not funny it's
not cute it's really disturbing they all
know one who kind of escapes unscathed
is Leonardo but that's just cuz he's
bland he's always been bland how you
upped the quotient on bland he can't
he's still bland you know I did
everything I could to try and give this
film a fair shake and there are even a
couple of scenes that work honestly when
they're in the elevator waiting to go up
and they start banging out that beat you
start beatboxing that was awesome when
that showed up at a trailer I was like
okay yeah because that was a good
encapsulation of sort of their teenage
nature that they are ninjas and they are
fighters they are intimidating but
they're also impatient if they're stuck
in an elevator you're gonna find a way
past the time yeah that was fun and it
was funny and it worked
splinters first fight scene not the one
he's got with shredder but when he's
taking on members of the Foot Clan
honestly really cool fight see really
well executed really well done and you
know I'm pretty sure there are some
people who are gonna say look dude chill
out it was for kid I reject that
argument for two reasons first of all
the current TV incarnation that is aimed
kids and is doing these characters and
these stories so much better than this
movie does just objectively secondly
this is pg-13 now I know a lot of people
are gonna say well kids love Cerrillos
they love Ironman they lost my man those
are pg-13 yes they are but they're not
dumbed down the way that so many films
made explicitly for kids are they are
made for the fans of all ages which
includes kids and if you're gonna defend
this film on the basis of it was made
for kids therefore it's allowed to be
stupid nah if you do that you don't get
to make it pg-13 it should have been PG
if that was your goal it's not it
shouldn't exist and personally I'm gonna
try and pretend for the rest of my life
like it doesn't if you are a Ninja
Turtles fan at all what is your
preferred incarnation of the Ninja
Turtles is it one of the TV shows is it
some of the movies is it some of the
comics whatever it is drop something
down in the comments
let's talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned